Al-Qaïda intensifie ses menaces contre
la France Le Figaro publie ce matin une
note confidentielle du contre-espionnage
révélant qu'une centaine d'Européens
dont plusieurs Français suivent
actuellement un entraînement dans les
camps du groupe terroriste Frédéric Vion
les camps d'entraînement d'Al-Qaïda en
Afghanistan et au Pakistan n'accueille
pas seulement des locaux et des
ressortissants de pays arabes mais aussi
une centaine d'Européens et au moins 14
français c'est ce que croi savoir les
services de renseignement la DCRI selon
frère du Figaro une information
inquiétante d'abord parce qu'osama Ben
Laden a nommément désigné la France
comme cible d'attentat futur et aussi
parce que les Occidentaux surtout les
fraîchement convertis sont souvent
encore plus radicaux et plus difficiles
à repérer par la police c'était par
exemple le cas de ce converti
britannique dont la bombe a tué 26
personnes dans le métro de Londres en
2005 en France la police affirme que de
nombreux prêche très radicaux seraiit
prononcés dans certains lieux de culte
surtout depuis les soulèvements en
Tunisie et en Égypte
des appels à combattre l'Occident et à
instaurer à la place des gouvernements
Benali ou Mbarak un régime de
charia